okay it's been a very busy day and now
I'm hearing a decision is about to be
made on Babylon 52 welcome to sere your
scii TV and Movie Channel while I'm
doing videos when I should be
[Music]
working yes I'm a very naughty boy doing
videos to update you about what's going
on in the world of science fiction when
I should actually be you know doing
paperwork I know what I'd rather be
doing but I have just had an email from
one of my very reliable sources
basically saying that there were
discussions last week at Warner Brothers
about what to do with Babylon 5 Warner
Brothers are still very keen to move
forward to the project but it still
looks like it will not be going to the
CW they have other priorities and they
100% don't want to pay as much as Warner
Brothers think the show will cost so
right now it does seem that Warner
Brothers do want to push forwards that
was basically the result of the meeting
last week but it will not be going to
the CW and many of you might go
harah there are though a lot of things
going on at Warner Brothers at the
moment Warner Brothers are looking to
invest very heavily and potentially Buy
Paramount Picture Studios now this is a
rumor that has been knocking around for
a little while and actually I've got a
video talking about it tomorrow or
Thursday I forget um because this
relates to a
potential interest in story around Star
Trek but the deal doesn't just involve
them buying um param mounted advis them
buying Paramount Studios but actually
potentially Netflix coming in and um
potentially also Netflix taking over Max
the HBO streaming service so now this is
going to be a massively complicated deal
so before I even get into it a little
bit more I'm going to say that this is
still very very early doors if it were
to happen it would be an insane credible
deal especially considering Warner
Brothers owe $50 billion so it would be
surprising to be honest if this pulled
off and the whole reason why Netflix are
involved is because of the massive debt
and it's the only way sort of a deal
could be structured Paramount is
basically too big to be sold as one
entity and would have to probably be
split up a little
bit but this is relevant to Warner
Brothers because I told you oh God
nearly six months ago now that Netflix
were part of the conversation with
Warner Brothers for Babylon 5 and so
were Amazon now Amazon we're having a
conversation of a basically where to put
it should should Babylon 5 go to Prime
which would then probably get a slightly
healthier budget than its other option
of putting on free I actually talked at
the time that I thought that's basically
not a bad idea I can kind of see bab R 5
on freee I'd quite like it I know we'd
have we'd have to live with the trailers
I know it'd be like being back in 2005
again we would have to deal with the
trailers but it's just a show that feels
like it would fit on free to me I don't
know what you guys think get into the
comments and tell me but
those are the two options and those are
the discussions that are happening
apparently Netflix are still in that
conversation and particularly if they
want to do this deal in future Warner
Brothers and HBO have already been
really working very closely with Netflix
Netflix have actually bought a couple of
shows directly from HBO Max which
doesn't really happen normally and I
mean that show is produced by Warner
Brothers for HBO that normally go
straight and and in the past have gone
straight onto Max now go to Netflix that
does show that there's that relationship
already it does look like initially
Amazon will winning this race but now
potentially Netflix might be actually
where the show ends up so that's where
we're at right now conversations are
going on JMS I don't know if he's
involved in those conversations or not
yet but I imagine he will be getting a
phone call soon if he isn't so the
businessmen are trying to figure out
what to do with this before they go on
to the creative side of things but it
looks increasingly like it won't be the
CW let's just hope they get on the phone
to JMS quickly and they get this project
up and running
fast if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to c.co where we do
stories based on most of our videos and
we tried to add a little bit more detail
for you to digest also you can go to
patreon.com where most of our videos
Premiere first and you get to see them
without the adverts you know and you get
free gift after three months can't be
that right I better get back to work cuz
I'm a bad bad man but you know I wanted
to give you this update as quickly as I
could as always please stay safe and
I'll catch you next
[Music]
time